okay so
uh thanks everyone i'm grayson i'm a
scientist at octon
and i'll be telling you a little bit
about my work in graduate school
where we were using crispr cast 9 as a
tool to unstudy cancer
i'll just give you um a little bit on
insights and lessons learned
in the field of targeted therapy and so
can answer an umbrella term used to
describe
um really over 200 uniqueness and
their the kind of unifying feature of
all of these diseases is this hallmark
of
uncontrolled cell growth in the last
decade
our 15 or so years um with the advent of
sequencing becoming cheaper
we've really become to appreciate the
genealogical
events
[Music]
we've appreciated that there are
communicated oncogenes that exist
in cancer types some of which i'm
listening here
for example egfr mutations in lung
cancer through ca mutations in
breast cancer vraf mutation melanoma and
on the heels of these findings
the field is also rapidly discovered
small molecule
inhibitors and in some cases antibiotics
that target the mutant protein products
of genes
and these inhibitors are known as
molecular targeted therapies um
they have been paramount in our thinking
about how to design precision medicine
therapies the problem with these
that was quickly realized when they were
put into patients
is that with with very few exceptions
nearly every molecular targeted therapy
exhibits properties of resistance
uh and or acquired resistance in the
context that
they're used
and there's perhaps no better tool to
really illustrate
both the same disease setting and so
about 50 percent of wall melanoma so
sorry to interrupt your connection um
seems to be cutting
in and out and so it's uh disrupting the
presentation i just wanted to see if
there might be another
connection uh or network that you can
use and and maybe that will kind of put
out some of the buffering
let me see possibly let me go to
this one
okay can you hear me i can hear you
awesome alrighty it looks pretty stable
okay hopefully this works yeah
just checking a few things on my end
real quick
sorry to have to cut you off like that
no it's okay
i guess we'll see how it works i mean
the other option i have is to
is for us to if it keeps not working as
i can
try to book time in the office
and hopefully that wi-fi works better
and we can reschedule but
yeah it's it's an at-home life is
is a struggle with i know wi-fi
i'm just clicking through to all of the
slides because i had to exit the
oh good good you're on it perfect yeah
once you do that
just let me know and you can select your
first slide again
i'm just looking pretty stable i haven't
seen any kind of
buffer just yet so that's good
[Music]
awesome
awesome just almost there
one of the oh one of the slides is being
a little bit
weird well will the slides click through
as i do it like on the
they will yeah so as you're
transitioning through or
animations on your slide they will uh be
picked up and
recorded as you do got it so i'm trying
to make sure that this
works okay that it clicked through that
time so hopefully
on the live it perfect it works
okay all right i think that should be
good i'm ready awesome
okay this time i'm gonna give you a
countdown from
five and i'll cut myself off around one
or two just to get a clean cut
and then you can get started again if
anything comes up
i'll be sure to let you know hopefully
connection stays strong so we don't have
to look to reschedule if anything we can
always do an audio only recording if
that's necessary
so we do have a few options there but
everything's looking good so i will let
you know if anything comes up
awesome starting from the top uh yes
starting from the top if you
are okay with that perfect
okay starting in five four
three two
hi thank you um my name is grace
anderson i'm a scientist
at octant and i'm going to tell you a
little bit about
some of my graduate work from duke where
we were using
crispr cas9 as a tool to model and study
cancer
and many of the insights and lessons
learned here will be
from the field of molecular targeted
therapies
so cancer is really an umbrella term
used to describe
over 200 unique diseases
and really the kind of unifying feature
of all of these diseases
is this hallmark of uncontrolled cell
growth
and so the last sort of 15 years or so
with the advent of sequencing technology
has really given us an appreciation
of many of the genes that are commonly
mutated
in various cancers and we call these
oncogenes
they're things like egfr pic3ca
bref and others and with the
appreciation of these commonly mutated
oncogenes
we on the heels of that as a field have
developed
many small molecule inhibitors that
inhibit the protein products of these
new
genes and these inhibitors have been
paramount
in um in altering our thinking about how
to treat cancer
but unfortunately um in in virtually
every case
of molecularly targeted therapies that
have gone into patients
uh to date there exists intrinsic
and or acquired resistance to these
molecularly targeted therapies and
there's perhaps
no better example for both of these
concepts in the same disease
than that of uh vemma afenib treated
uh breath mutant melanoma
and so about 50 of all melanomas
harbor activating mutations in a driver
oncogene
b ref this leads to constitutive
signaling through the mek
erk growth and survival pathway
and as i mentioned vamarafenib was
developed to target the
mutant version of b-ref that's present
in these
tumors and when it was put into patients
um which what i'm showing you here is a
waterfall plot of the clinical trial
where each bar represents a different
patient
and on the y-axis you have the percent
change
in baseline of a target lesion
so the first thing you can appreciate is
despite the fact that every patient here
has an activating mutation in braf you
can see there's
a great virginity with respect to the
response of their tumor
on the left you have tumors that exhibit
almost no response
or or just continue to grow even in the
presence of this drug
these are what we would call in the
field intrinsically resistant
so despite having the molecular
alteration that should make them
sensitive
these tumors are insensitive to this
drug
then on the other end you have what are
known as complete responders so
uh patients so these are now famous
photos of a man who
who comes into the clinic he has
metastatic melanoma
you can see lesions all over his body
he's given this drug this was considered
miraculous at the time he he comes to
the clinic 15 weeks later
and you can see he's visibly healthier
and nearly all of his lesions
are no longer visible so they've all
kind of shrunk um to mac uh from
macroscopic down to
uh undetectable disease and you can see
that
that's what is known as a complete
response this is something that hadn't
really been seen with a single drug
in in cancer before
unfortunately for for this man and is
the case for every patient that
that has been treated with this drug uh
as just several weeks later he comes
back and in the presence of the drug you
can see he's in a full-blown relapse
all of his lesions are back and he has
even new lesions that were not present
initially
and this phenomenon of undergoing a
response and then eventually relapsing
is what's known in the field as acquired
resistance
and the reason that i was interested in
in this phenomenon in graduate school
is because although vemma raphanib gave
a very meaningful shift in
progression-free survival
something that's meaningful to the lives
of these patients
the unfortunate result is that despite
that shift
by the seven to nine month mark all
patients are in the same boat and
and um and it's very common for
molecular targeted therapies to have
robust progression-free survival curves
that just do not translate into
overall survival curves so it was really
necessary to figure out how to tackle
intrinsic resistance
and so i'm going to use some work in
keras mutant cancers
targeting intrinsic resistance to mount
kinase pathway to really highlight three
learning objectives the first is
learning a scalable method to
systematically define
combination therapies in tissue culture
models of oncogene-driven cancer
identify the challenges still with two
body
combination therapies um and then begin
to explain rational is that one could
design
even higher order combination therapy so
three body
combination therapies that could
potentially make these precision
medicine approaches
more durable so why
k ras well uh i was interested in keras
because
it's of its penetrance across all
cancers keras is one of the most
commonly mutated oncogenes
it's mutated in about a fifth of all
cancers
if you break that down to various
subtypes you can see
that there are some cancer types like
pancreatic cancer where
over 95 percent of patients
have activating mutations in this
oncogene and you can see the
the percentages are quite high in
colorectal and lung cancer as well
and uh mutations in krs really
ultimately lead to constitutive
activation of the irk
survival pathway and the the work
in in the lab that i was in as well as
many other labs at the time really had
already highlighted that
monotherapies targeting this pathway
were not
going to be effective in treating these
complex tumors
and that was likely due to the presence
of many different effector pathways
downstream of
of keras activation as well as uh
feedback loops that would reactivate
this pathway
in the presence of an inhibitor
and so it became very clear at the
outset that combinatorial treatment
strategies would likely be necessary in
this context
but the challenges that existed were
really
you know what are the sensitizers that
you
so what proteins can you block in
combination with this pathway
that would actually produce a more
dramatic response and a more durable
therapy
how do those vary across tissues it was
not at all clear whether the same
sensitizer would exist in one tissue
type and
exist in all other krs driven tissue
types
and then what would determine the
heterogeneity that you saw
within a single tissue type so back to
that melanoma example
is there any way we can determine why
some of those
tumors respond very robustly to
inhibition of b ref
but others don't despite the fact that
they all harbor the molecular alteration
that should allow them
uh to be sensitive and so starting just
um with the first point uh learning a
scalable
method to to define these therapies
um at the time that this was started um
another graduate student like peter
winter had just
um read uh the sabbatini labs crispr
paper for the first genome scale
crispr screens and we decided that we
would
uh we would design a scalable crispr
based method so rather than a genome
scale
we would we would take a list of
candidates
we settled on 400 genes and we would
uh clone five guides per gene and 50
non-targeting controls
into a lentiviral based
crispr knockout screening system and we
would use that to screen
many cell lines across uh several drug
conditions
and so the way that our screens would
work is we would take our cells
we'd introduce our guide rna library
lentivirally such that
each cell was statistically likely to
only get one construct
and then we would select until we had a
pure population
once we had a pure population of cells
expressing guide rnas
we would split them into vehicle and
drug-treated conditions
the drugs we were interested in were map
kinase inhibitors
and then we would carry that across
three weeks
and at the end we would deconvolute with
next-gen sequencing
interested in was sensitizer so
things that would drop out of the drug
treated sample
but not the vehicle treated indicating
that those were somehow
interacting with the map kinase drugs
because we developed this to be scalable
in a matter of two months we were able
to screen 12 cell lines
across four tissue types for for a total
of 94 screens
with replicates and just a bird's eye
view here i'll
kind of talk about some of the the hits
we found but just
looking kind of globally at the results
here i'm showing you the hits across all
of our screens
along the top you have the different
genes that scored as hits
along the right side you have the
various screens so the different cell
lines we screen
color coded by tissue type and the open
or hashed box indicates what drug was
treated
and then we just did some basic
clustering um to look at um
if any like global patterns emerged and
one of the
the obvious things looking at it this
this way is that there were actually
very few genes that spanned
all tissue types and that was actually
surprising
given a lot of clinical trials in the
space were designed at the time
um to target k-rest driven tumors
and and there was not stratification
based on tissue type it was sort of all
comers for these mutations
but what we were finding is that many of
the regions of heat here so the red
indicates a potential sensitizer were
actually bounded
based on tissue type and and we
validated several of these but one i'll
just highlight here
is p38 was one of those hits that that
was tissue specific
it was strong in lung cancer and strong
in colon cancer
but very weak in pancreatic cancer and
so you're looking at on the left
the blue and red dots are lung and colon
cancer and you can see we get nice
depletion
um in in our screen but the green dots
are pancreatic cancer and you can see
um this hit does not this this gene does
not score as a hit in pancreatic cancer
and when we take that into in vitro
assays
we can actually see that we're able to
validate with gi 50s
that lung cancer cells produce robust
leftward gi 50 shifts when you add a p38
inhibitor on top of a map kinase
inhibitor but in pancreatic cancer cells
this effect is not present and so
that was very informative given
um given that we just really didn't have
an appreciation for whether the
signaling architecture was similar
enough
in all krs mutant cancers that you could
potentially target the same
uh the same sensitizers in addition to
kinase pathway
and so kind of looking more closely at
what these hits
are we were actually able to
recapitulate
about five years of targeted therapy
research
in this one scalable screen by by going
across multiple tissue types we were
able to pick up
um what was known in the field to be
bona fide sensitizers to map kinase
inhibition would be
nodes for pathway reactivation and also
bypass signaling in the akt
mtor pathway and so that was really
great to see because it really
highlighted
the power of of the scalable screening
but we were also able to find uh things
that had been less appreciated in the
literature
um and identify um on the order
of of 80 new combination therapies in
the k-rest
disease space and these were across
cell cycle regulators metabolism rtk
signaling
epigenetic modifiers basic survival
signaling
as well as transcriptional nodes
in these cells um and so
ultimately we followed up on
on one of these combinations that was
quite interesting
because of uh of
uh this feature that our scalable
screening pulled out which was
um because we could screen across
multiple cell lines
we were actually able to pick up on hits
um that were heterogeneous within a
tissue type and so back to that
phenomenon of breath mutant melanoma
where you were seeing heterogeneity with
respect to
the tumor's response we actually saw
that
in our screens and this was the power of
being able to screen multiple cell lines
because our libraries were smaller
and so what i'm showing you here on the
top is a screen in a
both of these cell lines top and bottom
are keras mutant
colon lines on the top you can see sarc
scores as the strongest hit in in
the krs mutant colon line at the top
at the bottom it actually stark wouldn't
even pass our hit calling criteria
and we were able to actually settle that
this
this difference in response was strongly
correlated with the presence of a
secondary mutation in pic3ca
so what i'm showing you here is a
sensitization score the higher the value
the stronger the leftward shift in the
gi50
and you can see cell lines that had both
mutations color coded in red
were more likely to respond to this
combination
of sarc plus map kinase pathway than
cell lines that either had a keras
mutation a pic3c
mutation or neither mutation and this
bore out in
apoptosis induction as well and so if
you just focus on the far right bars
that's the combination of an irk
inhibitor and a stark inhibitor
and you can see the double mutants
color-coded in red
have a robust response and the single
mutants or
cell colon cancer cell and with neither
don't respond to this combination at all
and so we ultimately wanted to
understand
what sarc was doing in these cells why
was that secondary modification of
pic3ca
responsible for these cells responding
to a stark inhibitor
and ultimately um the story shook out
that
what was happening is that in the double
mutant cells
sark inhibition was actually leading to
decreases
in akt activity so if you just look at
that top
phosphate akt t308 every time we treat
with a sarc inhibitor
you see decreases in that activity but
if you look at the two cell lines on the
right
you don't see that same effect and
so we took this combination in vivo and
we're able to show
on the left you have akt plus mech which
was
already a known combination
on the right you have stark plus mac and
you can see it fina copies it nicely
but the but the remarkable thing here is
actually that
in in uh patients akt
plus mech with inhibitors that were best
in class at the time
was ineffective because uh you reached
toxin target inhibition in an actual
human
and so although this combination was
very effective
in vitro and in vivo um clinical trial
data was actually quite disappointing
and so we were excited by the
identification of sarc because it was
seeming to work through the same
mechanism
but sarc inhibitors had been known to be
quite tolerable in patients for some
time in leukemias
and so we became interested in trying to
figure out
what it was about these two pathways
that led to such robust
apoptosis induction and ultimately we
were we were able to determine
actually that from for most of the
combination therapies we looked at
in this work i'm only showing you um
sarc plus mac
but uh nearly all of them worked in in a
similar manner where
the combination of both of these drugs
led to
robust induction of a pro-apoptotic
protein bim
but in the single mutant cell lines or
cell lines that didn't have any mutation
you can actually see that not only is
there not an induction of this protein
but there's actually just kind of more
of this protein already present
it's just hanging around indicating the
cells have already kind of figured out a
way to deal with having bim
and so this combination therapy
um not only does it not induce them but
these cells are just less primed
to die through uh bim induction
and we were able to show that bim was
was necessary for this effect so if you
knock out
bim in the double mutant cells they
don't die when you add a sarkin neck
inhibitor
but more surprising was actually if you
if you over express them which is again
a
powerful pro-apoptotic protein you see
specific
induction of apoptosis in the double
mutant cells
not in the the cells that are only krs
mutant
and through some collaborators at unc we
were able to obtain patient samples that
had various
uh constellations of mutations and when
we stain for bim we can actually see
that
on the top right panel you can see in a
double mutant setting you get nearly
no bim staining which is
very much in line with what our cell
lines were showing
but in a patient sample that is wild
type for these two genes you actually
see
quite a decent amount of bim staining
really um uh correlating
well with what we were seeing in vitro
and so this was
this was excellent it was a candidate
combination uh
therapy in a disease setting that was
currently not targeted
uh by um by any molecular targeted
therapies
but we were noticing uh a lot of similar
challenges to two body combination
therapies that the field had already
appreciated with
molecular targeted therapies used as a
monotherapy
and so
you know we we had run into this
challenge of when we identify
all of these combinations how do we
decide which ones to proceed with
there's short term in vitro assays so we
were finding that
all of these combination therapies in a
three day or two day assay
gave remarkable results we would get
leftward shifts in gi 50 massive
apoptosis induction and then we would
take these
combos in vivo and we actually saw that
many of these were not giving us the
durable responses in vivo
so there was a disconnect between the
short-term
response and the long-term durability
so that suggested that in vivo
experiments might be necessary
for all of these and as you know if you
have 80 combination therapies
it would be very time intensive and very
expensive at scale
to put all of these in vivo as a
head-to-head so we really wanted to
come up with a way to credential these
therapies and compare them head-to-head
that
um would kind of hit the middle ground
between these two initial
field standard approaches and so
we took an approach from the bardelli
lab and really into
implemented it in this context and it's
what we call
a long-term in vitro assay we call it a
time to progression
and we really refer to this in our lab
as the goldilocks approach for rapidly
screening these combination therapies
and the way that this data looks i'll
show you one combo
here before revealing kind of what all
of the combinations in colon cancer look
like
on the x-axis you have the days that
our cells are being cultured in the
drugs and you can see this is a
term in vitro assay we we took this
particular one out to 60 days
on the y-axis you just have the log of
normalized counts and this is just a
cell count
actually and we've just normalized it um
to vehicle treatment alone and you can
see the light gray bar
is our sarc inhibitor alone so you can
see at this dose
it's very quick to grow out these cells
don't care that much about that drug by
itself
you can see the primary drug alone in
the darker gray
that's our mech or erc inhibitor and you
can see
although the cells are a little bit more
than the sarc inhibitor
they still grow out pretty quickly
within 20 days you're already getting
exponential growth
but the combination of the two really
does lead to
a robust and durable response here so
out to 60 days these cells are
are suppressed and when we took all of
our combinations in colon
cancer and we screen them in this way
again
intensive but not as intensive as doing
in vivo screens
of all of these combos we saw that
there was massive heterogeneity with how
durable these were
long term despite the fact that um short
term
we actually wouldn't have been able to
easily identify which combination to
move forward they all have
very strong gi 50 shifts and very strong
short-term apoptosis induction and so
you can see actually there's a
a large number of these that are not
durable
long-term in vitro which would suggest
to us that they
should not move in vivo because the
response would likely be less impressive
there
but we were able to identify
five combinations including the one that
we had characterized
that were great candidates for moving in
vivo and further characterization
and so um this was an important lesson
for us
um because it also highlighted what
learning objective three is
the need to actually design even higher
order combination therapies uh
and and think thinking about how you
would design a three-body combination
therapy
given uh that they you begin to run into
issues of toxicity
and just your combinatorial space
has increased so so vastly when you go
from two things to target to three
things to target that it's hard to know
exactly uh exactly what to pair with a
combo
so given that we had this list of
combination therapies
um we reasoned we could start from a
list of two body combination therapies
and use biology in the field
to guide us to rational ways
of adding a third drug to this and so
one of the first things we thought to do
was look at activation of compensatory
signaling pathways
so much like in monotherapy
cancer cells have a way of reactivating
or activating compensatory pathways to
rescue the blockade that you put on them
we reasoned that if if the cancer cells
can do it for a single drug
they might be able to do it for a common
a combination of two
and so remember i showed you the sarc
inhibitor
um was able to suppress akt signaling um
when i
when i i showed you that previously that
was at a six hour
and 24 hour time point if you actually
just expand that
to five days i'm showing you here post
three days
you can see actually that akt is no
longer suppressed
in the presence of a sarc inhibitor and
so
this suggests to us that the cells by
day five have already
activated a compensatory signaling
pathway to re-establish that akt
signaling
and so we reasoned that we should be
able to add an akt inhibitor
onto our mac plus sarc combo and that we
would be able to see
a more durable response and so this was
really just the proof of principle
um because as i mentioned mac plus akt
in vivo is
um you hit on target toxicity before you
get inhibition
of uh well you hit toxicity with the
compounds before you get
full inhibition of the targets but as a
proof of principle in vitro we were
able to see that our mech plus sarc if
we lowered the doses
of that um we would see outgrowth by 40
days
but if you add an akt inhibitor on top
of that combination
you can see that we're able to um to
make that com
that more durable and so this this
suggested to us that um
that you you could identify compensatory
signaling pathways
uh and that if a drug existed
blocking that compensatory signaling
pathway would be one rational way
of devising a triple body combination
therapy
and then once you define all of those
one could screen those
much in the same way using this
long-term assay
to put those head to head before putting
them in vivo
and so the the second way that we
thought to
rationally add a third drug onto
our combination therapies was actually
to just take advantage of the fact that
most of these combos were working to
induce apoptosis
so we we thought what if we could
enhance that process somehow
and so before i i talk about the
compounds that we were using to do that
i just want to lay the kind of signaling
pathway in where these proteins kind of
fall
on on intrinsic apoptosis and so
you know you have your cell it's hit
with some sort of
of stimulus that induces apoptosis and
you get kind of your canonical
macroscopic
um features of apoptosis if you zoom in
onto the mitochondria
what's happening is you get a
homologation of backs and back
which allows for the release of
cytochrome c into the cytosol
this is then able to go and interact
with
a protein called aph1 which allows
that entire complex to interact with
procaspase 9.
the formation of aph1 cytochrome c
in procaspase 9 leads to this complex
called the apoptosome
which allows for caspase-9 to
self-cleave
and initiate the cleaved caspase cascade
of
three and seven and once this occurs
the cell will ultimately die
and this process you can imagine of
mitochondrial outer membrane
permeabilization
is tightly regulated and the primary
regulators of this process
are the bcl2 family members of pro
and anti-apoptotic proteins so there
exists
the anti-apoptotic proteins that
actually work
by binding backs and back which are the
effectors
and preventing them from oligomerizing
and creating a pore
these proteins also have affinity for
activators of apoptosis so bim and bids
so they can prevent them from
even activating the effectors
and there's a further level of
regulation on this entire process which
are the sensitizer proteins
bad noxa puma hrk as well as a couple
others
those are actually inhibitors of the
anti-apoptotic proteins so they inhibit
the inhibitors so they themselves are
pro-apoptotic
and given the knowledge of how all of
this works
many groups had developed these
compounds called bh3 memetics
and those actually mimic the sensitizer
proteins
so they block these antibiotic proteins
basically a bh3 memetic would take the
breaks off of apoptosis would get rid of
that negative regulation
trying to prevent apoptosis from
occurring
so we reasoned that if you have a
combination that's working through
intrinsic apoptosis
you could define which anti-apoptotic
protein
was responsible for slowing down
apoptosis
and you could combine a bh rheumatic
that blocked that
with your and it turned out that this
worked quite well so
if we take the example that i've been
using the whole time
the irk or mac inhibitor plus a stark
inhibitor
and you do a times progression so you
can see um
the the bcl excel inhibitor alone so
that's the anti-apoptotic protein in
colon cancer that's very important
you can see it grows out very quickly in
this assay
the combination of a stark inhibitor
plus a bcl-xl inhibitor
or an earthquake inhibitor plus a bcl-xl
inhibitor
also grow out under 30 days
our original combination as i showed you
previously
grows out at about 40 days but you can
see here this combination was very
effective the three body was able to
hold
out to 80 days and i'll tell you we
actually carried this longer than that
there were just no more cells on the
dish so so there was no point to
continue carrying this
um nothing was ever going to grow out
because adding the bcl-xl inhibitor
actually allowed for
all of the cells to commit to apoptosis
so we took this in vivo and it turned
out that um
we saw results very similar to our in
vitro assay we were actually for the
first time
in this project able to achieve tumor
regression so not just the slowing
of our our tumor growth but
actually about two-thirds of the tumors
were exhibiting a regression from the
start of
treatment and that was exciting because
one of the primary concerns we had with
a three-body combination therapy was
that we would
quickly see toxicity in the mice what we
saw was that we were able to
use low enough doses of the sarc
inhibitor
the mac inhibitor and the trip and the
bcl excel inhibitor
to actually never approach uh 20
weight loss in our mice over the course
of the study
and so this was quite promising um for
a number of reasons um but one of which
being that
it it suggested that you could design
higher order combinations
that could effectively eradicate the
cancer cell population
but be tolerable at the organism level
and so quickly just to kind of wrap up
some of some of the things along the way
that we
we learned the first is you know this is
a great approach for
for systematically defining combination
therapies in tissue culture models of
oncogene
cancer the first thing i'll say is that
um in my postdoc i worked
with a a postdoc in my basics lab
who was showing that you could actually
develop
3d in vitro models that may better
reflect
even better reflect in vivo models and
that this approach because
it turns adherent cell lines into
suspension cell lines
may actually be scalable at genome scale
and the reason that's important is
because scalable
as my my friend peter and i who worked
on this project learned
scalable is sometimes another word for
bias and
so we hand selected 400 genes
which meant that our discovery space was
limited and so
while we were rapidly defining
combinations that nobody had found
before
we weren't uncovering new biology that
nobody had ever found before
and so this approach cited here
might actually allow you to have greater
discovery space but still be able to
screen
across multiple cell lines and multiple
drug conditions
the second lesson learned is that drug
resistance is still a problem
in complex tumors even with two drugs
and i will give you a little bit
of a teaser that even certain three body
combinations
in vitro still cannot
suppress resistance durably in
in these solid tumor cell lines so
there are still many challenges there
even with the
design of three-body combinations
and then third you you can use
[Music]
knowledge that already exists in the
field to rationally design higher order
combination therapies that can be
more durable than two body and certainly
more durable than monotherapy
and that you can do this through
targeting compensatory signaling
pathways
many of which are well understood in
these contexts
and through enhancing apoptosis by
targeting
anti-apoptotic proteins so many groups
define what anti-apoptotic proteins are
important in a given tissue type
and so leveraging that knowledge that
already exists
with the inhibitors that have been
developed could actually make these
combinations
more durable and so i will
uh leave it at that and we'll happily
answer questions that are sent in
thank you
all right hi grace um sorry change of
voice this is antonina
um tyler tyler had to jump out
um and just run into another recording
really quick so i just wanted to help
wrap you up but um just so you know
your connection um looked good it was
steady throughout the whole thing so i
think we got a good take
um so i'll just make a quick note for
tyler but i think we should be
good to go and then if you have any
other questions you can feel free to
email him
but i think he'll just quickly do a
heads and tails edit and it should be
ready
perfect awesome thank you of course
thank you i hope you have a good rest of
your day
awesome take care bye
[Music]